hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to through the Portola
okay we just escaped from some
diabolical demon from another dimension
I should have said from a different
dimension that would have been more
alliteration there and everyone knows
how great alliteration is right right
right
okay nevermind now we're going up these
stairs here I'm actually curious about
that door that was locked before but I
feel like if there's anything essential
there it'll make me go back I still
don't know how they do these projected
lights because they're actually just
projected onto the surface see they sync
up and they stretch out I really don't
know I'm actually quite confused about
it but and I'm kind of worried about
where the staircase is leading me ah
epic ooh burn s alright here we go time
the master chamber alright I can dig it
holy crapola
okay all right
Wow what a hack
what duh I guess since I said all alien
artifacts it shouldn't be surprised
Oh pick up damasco orbit radiates with
incomprehensible energy is that is that
correct in comprehendible I think it's
incomprehensible
I regret I resign my position as head
researcher after the research recent
incident I cannot bear that pain again
there's too much we don't understand
about the master or bandits Guardian I
will not lose another for scientific
gain the red Nayla there will be nothing
to stop scientific progress we must
sacrifice everything okay so I get a
feeling that a guardian is about to
start chasing me up
yep it babe perhaps the master orb can
be used in a great underground to
activate the unpowered portal to earth
maybe maybe baby baby but it seems that
I have angered something for really
diabolical well here's hoping I don't
die Oh ha ha ha
screw you you're just gonna kill me if I
tried to put it back nope uh-huh screw
you gooey ol face ha ha ha jump jump
epic shortcut now shortcut this isn't in
short cut I don't think it's just
hurting me
yah-ah-ah gooping oh that's not good hey
where'd that come from
I don't know oh this this Guardian is
not happy with me oh boy okay it's still
chasing me right probably others I said
Oh get out of here get out of here get
out of here get out of here
get out of here oh boy I hope this isn't
the end
I'd be Allegan fortune I'm gonna put it
back right here right here huh nope
that's wrong
that was wrong where'd he go where'd he
go can I not put it here
all right let's go to the unpowered
portal to earth to to the earth hmm DDT
bark
digits work was with this tree here home
I can find go home I get the feeling
that's not the end of the Guardian I get
the feeling that's not the end of
anything here splint
interesting I'm back I'm back in the
chamber
where Alexander died as the skull will
profess ah so I can't go back I'm
assuming just as long as before huh
it's exactly the same amount of who has
locked as it was this doors it's not
here for them in passage a
yeah well now let's just see about this
let's look I trust this you know I
realize now that I've never really
gotten any more oil maybe they never
intended for me to get any more
exactly sure maybe this is the end I
have no idea
what the heck no way this is the
beginning of him nature oh it's been so
long since I've been here oh my god I
gotta go over here oh look it was a
tinderbox in here or something and then
with this lock but that's okay you can't
stomach this road again I can stomach it
oh man I remember I remember you broom
I remember this broom ha ha ha I
remember that shirt I remember this pink
cotton candy on the floor oh I remember
this man I was like total now Stella's
you up in here
I'm like freaking out howdy about a
tinderbox
oh man in this passive way ever here was
blocked yeah oh yeah oh yeah so cool
Allah so cool ah man wait he waited why
didn't I just leave this place ah I
remember this room it's always been here
maybe it was I I remember oh yeah
my favorite weapon come here yeah
there's the end I won't carry you out of
here my friend it's so pretty
I shouldn't be holy this chair found 11
of 11 notes yeah
secret room found I know that was a
secret room I knew it was a secret room
oh I knew it was gonna be a secret I
shush shut up shut up
I shoulda I should I should ha ha ha ha
well I was quite interesting I mean for
as short as it was they put a lot of
work into what it was so holy crap thank
you Scott so much for making good cuz I
was incredible that was just absolutely
impeccably detailed the intricacies I
wish that there was more done with the
red Guardian The Guardian in the pasture
or Blake like if you wanted to add more
you could have been chasing through more
of the complex you know it sort of stock
you as you needed to find other things
to activate the portal or something like
that I don't know but you could uh but
it's okay because the way was it was
fantastic so thank you so much ha ha I
love I love custom stories and try to
add so much more like this so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye